the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
we talk about something we've sort of
touched on in many different contexts
but most head on this time that's an
entrepreneurship and sort of the
starting point of that I think it's
rizal there's a story that somebody once
told me which was I thought kind of
frames one side of the debate very well
I was in the plane with a man who was
clearly you know sort of a rich indian
businessman and he was quizzing me about
what I did and I said I study economics
and poor people and he said you know he
was very much of the view he said look
you know there's always stuff for poor
people you guys don't understand poor
people there they have there they have
entrepreneurial geniuses in them you
think I'm anantapur successful
entrepreneur the way allah learnt
entrepreneurship was from the poor so I
was kind of saying yeah I i well that
then he told me a story there was
actually quite compelling I mean mostly
people this whatever this means it's not
as never clear to me so I was being
slightly skeptical but then he told me a
story was very compelling so he said
that when he he had an MBA from the US I
think from kellogg and he went back to
India after doing his mba and he when he
arrived in India his uncle who was a
businessman in Bombay said look you want
to be an entrepreneur let me show you
what entrepreneurship is so his uncle
basically they got in a cage uncle's car
uncle drew
of him all the way to the Bombay Stock
Exchange one way stock exchange well he
thought that they would just go inside
the stock exchange but in fact he parked
his car in front of the exchange and
pointed to for women who was sitting on
the side of of the street that goes in
front of the exchange and said you know
can you figure out what those women's
business model is so it's so he says
well I looked and look and they will
just get up from time to time they'll
scrape something of the off the street
then they'll come and sit down and then
they'll be sitting and talking to each
other so early in the morning like eight
thirty in the morning a nine in the
morning dozen you know cars were driving
by people were showing up in this to
work at the stock exchange but what is
this have anything to do with
entrepreneurship so you know he kind of
you know he tried to come up with some
answer completely didn't manage and
finally I told his uncle look I have no
idea why did you tell me sankalp said
these women get up at five thirty in the
morning they go to the beach we go in
the morning this the tide has receded so
the this wet sand on the beach this they
collects a wet sand and then they put in
a bag they come to the stock exchange
this is one place where lots of cars go
by and there's a nice sidewalk to sit so
they lay before the traffic starts
they'll lay the sand out on the street
and then they sit there
and as people drive on the sand the heat
from the tires dries the sand so the
sand sand sand gets heated and
eventually drive by the tires once the
sand is fully dry the scrape of the sand
put it and put it put it in a bag and
take it back to the slums where they
live women use this dry sand as like a
scrubber to clean clean dishes you use
this dry sand as a scrubber for that and
so they use this dry sand to scrub off
there you know dirty dishes and that's
how our dirty I know whatever go pots
and pans and that's how this we will
make a living they they they did it did
dry the sand and they sell it so this
was this was his example of you know how
infinitely creative poor people are and
my reaction to that was you know
isn't that saying much more about how
creative you have to be to make a living
if you're poor then how creative the
poor are so it's sort of you it's the
same same proposition in a sense you
could say that this shows that the poor
are very creative or you could show that
the poor have no business opportunity so
they have to do this completely bizarre
thing to make a living and those are
just two sides of the same coin and you
know I I don't know so what I will talk
about today is a bit on on you know this
this implicit and often explicit debate
so before we get there on whether you
know for our entrepreneurial in some
meaningful sense of the word or not so
let's start with at the beginning who's
an entrepreneur how do you define an
entrepreneur
with undefined entrepreneur is someone
goes about creating new venture that
often involves a greater than average
amount of risk
so if i if I'm someone who you know
works for Toyota and designs a slightly
different car am I an entrepreneur why
not it's risk I got failed I would look
really really stupid to my bosses crazy
you venture a new venture so it has a
new separate companies is that the
definition no I'd say adventure not
design right but I haven't got what that
means so like a venture the sense of why
he does not have to be entirely own
company but more than just designed more
of a in a sense of like a design in the
design then you're not take
that going to say total decides to
launch a new life where they're going to
do a new dealership agreement you value
you venture I was running that theory
could be classified or my definition
okay so you you would okay go ahead yeah
you should be oh yeah besides just
creative nature we create a new venture
that it somehow innovative and unique so
I think whether or not necessarily the
business idea mrs. strategy product but
maybe even in the you know how the
person operates the concrete to give me
intrapreneurs in that way so you don't
think that if if I have a set of taxes
I'm an entrepreneur
i just bought a set of taxes I've end
them out well you're the only magic
through the person who started who took
the initiative to this was the after
there were have been 500,000 taxi
companies in the world if I go tomorrow
quit my job and I start a taxi company I
would not be able to connect what is
over you could say that still you need
is your star and tax income in your
particular city with a printer set of
drivers are busy but there everything is
unique once once I go down that road I
don't see how anything put mean there
will be a I can't have a crack c company
we say the same set of privacy everybody
are so this unique by deputies it so
somebody else from that side cygnett
sector financial risk is water
yourself as opposed to the responsible
for an organization right I think that
that's actually one key piece of what i
would consider the definition is the
fact that you the a lot of the risk
comes from raising capital that that
that the risk is a significant part of
the reason why if i were for toyota that
would not be it could be career risk for
me but it would not be risk that is
driven by my having to raise capital so
I think you are making I think making
one of the key points which is I think
that I think exactly as he said risk is
a big piece of it the next piece of it
is the risk comes from raising capital I
think that's that's that sort of i think
i would not say that it has to be a new
product because i think that's too
narrower definition i mean you could
define it but i think that would mean no
poor people are essentially
entrepreneurs but they're so but i think
raising capital financing the financing
side of it as well as the so do you take
the risk and a lot of the risk comes
from holding the owning the asset that's
generating the output i think that's
that's that i think is key part of being
an entrepreneur is that you you the risk
is comes from putting money or your own
assets on the line it's not just that
you are putting on your career or your
name on the line you know when i write a
book i also poor take a risk in that
sense people could say my god what a
stupid book that's a risk but it's not i
wouldn't call myself an entrepreneur so
i think that i want to i think i'm gonna
emphasize that i think the poorer
entrepreneurial when we talk about
somebody's an entrepreneur i'm going to
emphasize the fact that they they bear
risk a lot of the risk of the from
production and/or and that risk is
closely tied to the ownership of the
asset so it is that they have to finance
the finance the asset and hold on to the
wrist generated by that asset so if they
could be a farmer they have to somehow
find the way to you know they must have
to own the land
and then take the farming risk yeah a
lot of the people we think of as
entrepreneurs make it like venture
capital or somebody else has hit on
financial risk but kind of my interest
of their home but first I think nobody
gets hundred percent venture capital
funding I mean you know you you
basically even to get to the venture
capital stage you typically spend a fair
amount of money and nobody gets one
hundred percent funding even then and
second insights in some ways you still
take financial risk in the sense that
you you know you you are the upside on
on the venture capital is precisely your
earnings in the future so you basically
doc you're earning so you still you are
you have your own owner of the you have
arranged a particular form of financing
which says that I don't have to make any
payments for enough for the time being
on this financing but it's exactly like
any other form of financing it's just I
I have an obligation to pay you that
obligation in venture capital is maybe
in five years if the company goes to
goes public then i will pay you 100
million dollars that's a venture capital
contract it's it's still basically a
sharing of risk and off i'm taking
ownership of the asset it's just a
different contract yeah
like all quadrants could avert that but
that's a bit bit like I could have spent
my time consulting or I could write a
book I mean that's not that different
from I think the key is that it is it is
that my earnings are significantly
connected to the the outcome of the
project if you wrote a book this whole
you know 10 million copies or something
in your future earnings would be
significantly yeah but but boom mostly I
think a first order is a sadly for me is
is that people will just think I'm
stupid I think they I think the risk in
my case you could imagine everybody has
that a small chance of being an
entrepreneur but i think that mostly
most of my risk has something to do with
my ability to you know convince other
people that have not lost my marbles and
very little of my risk comes from money
money there are some people who are like
full-time authors and they take out
loans when they write this those are
they are often for no real I am NOT
saying they are not on troponin I think
I'm not an entrepreneur to first
approximation because my risk is mostly
reputational risk very little of it is
financial even though you're sort of
doing a similar thing yes but I very
it's not my lifetime earnings are
essentially mostly with a ninety-nine
percent probably are unaffected by this
this decision or almost an effect so who
is it isn't an entrepreneur so we've
sort of been talking about that I'm not
but who away who is so what's in clearly
some you know Larry page's Sergey Brin
are entrepreneurs now let's take
something less obvious what are other
phones on the phone
like in the u.s. less obvious once then
you know studying a software company
they like
that's all for now
that's on the pronoun so one thing I
kind of disagree with the fact that he
has to you gotta have some sort of her
is attached to to your venture yeah I
think it's a line starts a business that
focused on the surface but it's very me
intrapreneur I think that still know
that if it is novated in some way I
still think is chipping in to this entry
solution okay I think with who I'm going
to do I think people do use I think they
say say sometimes somebody a political
entrepreneur but i think that gets the
term to be little bit too hard to
understand I mean I think you could make
the case that you're making I'm going to
sort of resist that a little bit because
I think and then I don't know what the
limits are anymore who's not a political
entrepreneur if I go and you know claim
that President Obama was born in Kenya
I'm a political entrepreneur or not yeah
yeah there is that entrepreneurial yes
its entrepreneurial is he know you know
where to buddy I did I feel like that
that's making it too easy sure they were
they had put in there they had their cat
they had put their entire they own this
enterprise this their entire earnings
was subject to that they had financed
whatever it needed to be financed so
that they had paid for the you know the
plastic bucket with which they had
bought the collected the sand they were
spade they had paid the bus fare to get
to from the beach to thee to the Bombay
Stock Exchange they then all the
financial investment was involved it
just happens to be a small amount of
money but that doesn't mean that they
hadn't made done they had put in hundred
percent of the capital in there okay i
guess the example that but other example
just to not get too stuck on it lawyers
for example most lawyers are effectively
are entrepreneurs because the most
lawyers actually wore
you know they have a two-person
three-person partnership they're burying
a lot of risk they pay for the staff to
pay for the office they pay for the Deaf
pay for the whatever the furniture and
so in that sense they they would fall
under the definition also gone to serve
yeah doctors the same yeah a lot of
doctors it's all I think that's relevant
because when the typical way there is no
measurement of entrepreneurship in the
data because nobody knows was an
entrepreneur for the same reason as we
were having trouble with it what is
measured in the data is whether you
describe yourself as self-employed
that's described in the data so you can
collect if you look at most countries
one of the employment categories is
self-employed and that number which
includes lawyers doctors consultants
many other such people include not just
laundromat owners and Google owners but
lots of other people that category turns
out to be about twelve percent of the
population so twelve percent of
population under a very generous
definition of entrepreneur which is
self-employed are entrepreneurs that's
for the OECD OECD is like all the rich
countries in the world in rich countries
roughly twelve percent of the population
would call themselves self-employed that
number is much higher among the poor in
poor countries and I'm going to show you
some numbers so here's some some numbers
so
self employed in agriculture rural
population you can see that in many
countries over you know 75 to even a
hundred percent nearly are self employed
in agriculture take take Panama or
Pakistan like seventy percent of these
people are self employed in agriculture
meaning that they basically like up
e-exactly using the equivalent
definition to the one that's used in the
OECD which is that they describe
themselves are self-employed meaning
that typically they are putting up the
capital usually the land and the inputs
and they're getting the return so they
are risk taking all the bearing a lot of
risk and they are they they own the
assets that are generating that risk so
that's a number that's high on and
that's not as you will see that that
numbers in a sensor is an underestimate
of how many people are self-employed
overall so this is just enable
agriculture this is how many people who
have somebody who self employed in
non-agricultural work so in in Brazil
rural Brazil 60 something percent a
self-employed in non-agricultural work
so who are these people they're like
somebody who provides any services a
barber are carpenters somebody who
builds you know bricklayer all of these
people basically work as instead of
working as sort of a part of a company
most of these people just work as single
person enterprises so brick layers are
bricklayers they have a brick laying
company which is themselves and they
they typically will
the brick laying for somebody so it's a
in in sort of many ways these this is
another so if you so if you have to take
take the fraction of people who are
self-employed both either in agriculture
or not or somebody in their family is
self-employed in in either agriculture
or outside agriculture that's an even
higher fraction that's like seventy
seventy percent of most poor people
ourself have somebody in the family
self-employed so if you this is a
combination of these tuna two sets of
numbers so and some of them are both
some of them have one family members
help employed in agriculture somebody
one family member self-employed outside
agriculture but even you take that the
average ISM is quite a high number so
most most poor people in this definition
in our definition or at least
self-employed well why is this is yeah
I think here they are consider
self-employed but that's a good question
whether that she so why should we think
there is anything interesting about this
why should we why would it be at all
surprising if a lot of poor people where
entrepreneurs why would it be even worth
commenting on
I said that twelve percent of the like
people in rich countries are
entrepreneurs maybe seventy percent of
the poor in poor countries around why is
that is that something that has anything
interesting about that that fact and
there I want to get you to do these two
questions dupo is it the case that the
boar have specific advantages me in
entrepreneur do they have specific
disadvantage in the being on so let's
start with the disadvantages is that
clear
right so so risk is it is relatively
higher because they have you know they
really know where this came from but I
kind of know where it one should go yeah
so one thing that's clear is that
entrepreneurship is risky and if you are
if you can if you are you know at the
margin of you know not having enough
money for something really essential
than risk the same risk hurts you more
because you know you you're really in
danger or something awful happening if
you like you couldn't pay for your
mother's hospital stay if your business
collapse so you the risk is much more
important we talked about this some few
weeks ago other reasons other
disadvantages
sure how to raise capital if you don't
have a in if you don't have a bank
account you don't have assets that you
can pledge if you don't have contacts
among financials there's harder to raise
capital surely yeah
is it a disadvantage
I see so you may not have skills let's
get you an alternative job so your
business failed and it really hurts you
I see yeah like you're really important
Royer and marketing resources as far as
resources to prepare imagine baseball
right so you may not have the know-how
to be an entrepreneur you may not know
what market opportunities are available
because you're not that well connected
to the media you may have you may not
know even what the prices of the best
best prices are for what you will buy
and the best prices are what for what
you will sell where to sell all the
information that you need presumably
that's correlated with being educated
and so if you are poor in a poor country
you're less likely to have all of those
those all that information
this is something that affects the
guests are all
but i think it would be perfect for
thinking about the benefits
you get out there things like that or in
you know some business and so being on
your side taking the risk respect to
that and then
yeah it's also possible that there's
some some additional benefits to having
a steady job that particularly important
if you have no other source of support
let's do the disadvantages whole folder
yeah
yeah so thats related driving the first
point met with me
chances are not going to have an
original idea he copies well it before
yeah but why would why would we be less
to the poor the rich the rich might have
access to educational resource that
allows better ideas okay I mean you
could also make the conference argument
that since the Richard access to more
stuff and more likely to copy other
ideas but that will also be there would
have to be what they might not be as
likely to make a llama so those would be
the necessary
this is our said
thinking about life if you're poor
you're gonna have to use like in oxygen
or you let's say you had some savings so
you have family that was helping support
us of courses in the ass some sort of
capitalism is not that much when you're
poor you have lose everything which you
have to put into that business that
makes way from just living so you yeah
the risk is higher and the capital your
your axle your ability to sell finances
law
anything else yeah you could tell if
other people copied you just like the
supply but why would it be any different
for anybody else I mean if if I'm rich
and you copy my idea that still hurts me
it is not clear especially in a sense it
before poor use ideas that are
particularly you know they've already
copied from somebody they're less hurt
by copy yeah
we will support for an ability to check
that to enforce that right so you might
think that they have less and less
access to lawyers and things like that
they may not understand the law well so
they may not be able to use the legal
system to protect themselves as
effectively
what's another thing that you know in a
house company other than money and and
ideas what's the third thing that I
really server are you speaking like a
social safety net and this
absolutely there's still a social safety
net that you could rely so in thats
that's true of poor countries but not
necessary more of poor people they
that's a point about four countries less
about four people one other thing that I
think matters a lot is contacts I mean I
think that you know if you know somebody
who's who you know if your uncle is the
unix the CEO of a company there may be
more willing to give you a try if you
you're the startup starting up you're
going to you're making widgets somebody
has to buy them it's much easier if you
know somebody then if you don't when why
would anybody trust you so you get your
often get your first breaks by having
some connection to somebody else who
would do the buying and I think that's a
very big piece of what makes it very
difficult for the poor to be effective
entrepreneurs is that they actually
don't know anybody and so it's much
harder for them to break in with her
with a product so i think contacts are a
very big piece of it the other part of
it is that it it's in my it might be
that you know in order to be in business
for example take the venture capital
example typically the way a way a lot of
startups work is that you are you know
that you're going to lose money for a
while because you have to build a
reputation and the way you would build a
reputation is by going to someone and
saying look you buy them from him for
five dollars i'll sell it to you for
three and you know you lose money at
three but you're willing to lose money
for a while because that way he'll see
that you are really good at doing it and
then maybe you could charge for and get
the market so a lot of way a new
businesses start is by actually
undercutting other businesses and losing
money so if you can't lose money
effectively so if you're poor and you
have you can't afford to lose money it's
often very difficult
to enter a new product because you know
part of the way you enter the new
product is by by actually selling it
very cheap and it's very difficult to
sell it very cheap if you are if you are
you can't afford to lose money so all
those are all the disadvantages are the
advantages to being so I don't know how
many of you know but there's a very
famous book called the fortune at the
bar 0 bottom of a pyramid of the pyramid
that book if you read that book it makes
the case that is sexually lots of
entrepreneurial opportunities for the
poor and that in some sense they might
have an advantage what are the water
potential advantages yeah
right so they they might know about
things which are underserved so maybe
the way capitalism is developed it's
better at serving the demands of the of
the middle classes is the for my dream
on certain products which are not
supplied by the market so at this point
it might be easier to find new product
to supply if you know what the poor want
that's the K one of the cases as being
made we'll see whether to what extent
that's true any of us you are going to
mention something
they can go to the beach in civic center
but if someone was trying to use in the
larger scale
that's example that's exactly right so
it may well be that if I am the person
who comes and like so imagine that I'm
I'm rich then to be an entrepreneur to
compensate me for let's say I have to I
can either take a job or I can be and I
can either take a job or I can be an
entrepreneur to compensate me for my job
I would need to be able to do so the
business at a particular scale I'm
imagine I i I'm in the business of
sorting through garbage and finding you
know things which are saleable just
doing that physically you know if I
started to use that much garbage I'll
need a lot of space whereas the poor
person may you know may be able to cover
her daily wage which is very low by just
sorting through you know the garbage he
finds in a neighborhood or something
another advantage of being poor might be
that you may be less less concerned or
less easily monitored so you may be able
to bend the rules more effectively so
you might be able to you know to make
products which you know somebody else
would not want to do because it would be
too easy to scrutinize so you may you
may be involved in I'm not saying
illegal products but you might use
techniques which are possibly less
hygienic or something you may you might
so if I if I said of a big factory you
know dying garments that pollutes the
water supply and the city will shut me
down you have a very small operation
inside my house dying garments nobody
will notice and I could use the city's
water supply and polluted this doesn't
mean that I'm doing a good thing but it
means that it might be easier for me to
be an entrepreneur producing and do a
dying garments then somebody who's
richer than me so there's some some
potential advantages still I think my
sense is that everybody's would think
that it's basically it's easier for the
rich to be entrepreneurs than the poor
so that's unbalanced and we'll look at
this a little bit in the data in a bit
so then why are the poor entrepreneurs
that's the question then comes back if
it's a it's easier for the poor to be
rich to be entrepreneurs but the rich
are less likely to be entrepreneurs in
the poor then we have a kind of a puzzle
why are the poor entrepreneurs what is
it what is it that so one view of this
is sort of mahmoud unisys view more
eunice's the guy who started Grameen
Bank and he's on record saying that a
for a natural-born entrepreneurs so this
one view which is to say that something
something about the poor which by being
poured they have big they learn to be
entrepreneur they can't really survive
on anything else so they become like
this women we were talking about they
become very clever or finding
opportunities they are natural
entrepreneurs that's one way to think
about it is that when you are poor
you're just better at thinking of
opportunities now that's if you look at
one way we can kind of address this is
by looking at the business of the poor
what do we know about these businesses
and and here's here's a so these are
people who are under a dollar a day and
if you take the businesses of people who
live under a dollar a day I think the
striking fact is that in most countries
that for which we have data let's say
ten percent so that the average number
of employees in a business is point one
five it's one in seven businesses have
an employee a paid employee you know
they took two countries where that's
different and but even in those
countries they don't have one employee
they're fine six employees
so these are very small businesses the
first thing to note is that the business
of the poor are kind of very very small
businesses if you look at the this is
includes your you know unpaid employees
which is like your son or your wife or
you yourself and that number is just
over 1 so the average number of
employees is just over 1 so meaning that
is U plus somebody who's who works maybe
part of the time or alternately you it's
you or and no one or you plus one person
but not not much more than that so very
few employees but second what fraction
of the business is own a vehicle just
just to measure some this is some other
measure of the side of the business is
owning a vehicle in Pakistan is the one
country where many people own cycles
they might be delivering stuff but then
all the other countries is really really
small it's like five percent if you look
at a more even more obvious question
what fraction on machines any machine
the answer is not one hundred percent
even there sixty percent in the Ivory
Coast on any machine what's the average
machine that they own their own a
weighing scale or are you know ah
a sort of a piece of piece of metal for
you know digging or something but no
more than that so it's really like these
businesses have no assets whatsoever so
the first point about the business of
poor are they are very small by all
these measures they have no employees no
machines no vehicles the second related
so
the second related point I wanted to
make is that if you look at which
business this the fact that they don't
have any machines is telling you
something quite important which is that
these are not very sophisticated
businesses you're not surprised to hear
that but it is very very clear that the
average business has very little skill
involved and to be honest they're not
very there's not a lot of diversity you
look at the top five businesses they are
things like tailoring I reach a small
corner store selling snacks on the
street make it making you know making a
you know stitched abroad embroidering or
stitching clothes and selling them as a
kind of as a retail sale not a tailor
but somebody retail sales garments and I
think the last one is I forget car
painting I think it's like none of these
businesses except I think our printing
possibly require huge amount of skill so
they tend to be very low skill
businesses businesses where and this is
most businesses so these are not people
who are creating very original ideas
indeed the usual problem that people
write about is most people in the same
neighborhood of the same business
they're all selling snacks they're all
delivering floats they're all tailors
rather than a lot of innovation there is
no evidence that they are very creative
in what businesses they go into on the
other hand many many people own multiple
businesses
that's the other very very common fact
this is the fraction of people who own
who get incomes from multiple multiple
sectors so that's like somebody who has
a farming business but also has income
from let's say he does some brick lane
on the side that somebody who's who has
multiple sources and this striking fact
is how how common it is in most
countries is it's 50 close to fifty
percent of the population have incomes
from multiple sources so in other words
they are not putting all their time
available time into their own business
why would they not do that whoa why you
know if you have a business in your
family why aren't you putting all your
effort into it
why would we observe this fact that most
people many people have multiple
businesses a multiple okay so for
example you might be only able to sell
one kind of snack and people might want
snacks only like it you know maybe when
in the evening or something you know in
the morning you go to work there's no
demand for snacks or you might sell
breakfast and breakfast is only you know
you can only sell breakfast till 10 m
after that breakfast is over you have
shown you to find something to do so one
thing could be there's a natural
capacity constraint there's not much
demand for the product and so you can do
it for two hours a day but not for eight
hours a day yeah
ah
absolutely so every culture is one
classic business where you can work a
few months of the year within the rest
of the time you don't have irrigation
there's nothing to do so you work in
something else
Yeah right so you could get less you may
bear less risk by having multiple
businesses yeah
but why don't you take the one which is
the highest return and put all your time
into it why
but why would you go ever to start a
second even lower return business is
this one business this is the highest
return I want to put all your eggs into
that basket diversity yeah so that's
what she said which is that you going to
diversify risk what other reason could
you imagine for the gospel a man one
business is really powerful
but it might be you discern right that's
that's I think also someone yeah
like that I think they're like some
businesses which are like middle point
looks like physically hurt you if you do
it too much like people like become a
fly right so so you could maybe maybe
yes you don't want to do it for too long
another obvious reason
I
but why would you do three different
ones I'm asking a simple question and
the one you're answering which is people
seem to do two or three different
occupations why would you do two or
three rather than just I say I want to
work eight hours while I put all my
eight hours in the into one we've gone
through a bunch of reasons for that
this is right so it could be the
DiMaggio returns on the extra piece of
effort is no another possibility that i
think is more even more straightforward
is maybe some businesses require capital
and others look less capital so you want
you have a certain amount of capital you
put it into the capital intensive
business and then you still don't have
some time left so you work in the other
one you have to buy for example to
needlepoint you will have to buy fabric
first and you can only afford fabric
that covers half your day you buy fabric
for half your day you work half a day or
needlepoint rest of the half of your day
you you have something you have to find
something else to do so it may just be
that you don't have enough capital to to
make it possible to to spend your whole
day working on it so in any case we do
see this evidence that people don't seem
to they don't seem to be excessively
committed to any single business that
has the cost of cost obviously that they
are not very they're not getting a lot
of benefits from specialization they're
not very human they're not learning or
improving very fast because they're
doing many many things at the same time
this is the same fact which is that a
lot of them have a not a lot a lot of
them have these even rule rural
households what is striking about this
picture is this it says in even rural
households a lot of them have an on a
gray color business so they're actually
if you look at how many how many people
have an on agricultural business
like about a third of them have an on
agricultural business even if their
rural so these are people who live in
rural areas they they do farming as one
of their businesses probably but they
also have a second business which is
non-agricultural and that sort of
striking is that you know we think of
often rural areas in developing
countries farmers kind of living in
isolation in fact most of these people
are in us in a second business as well
so the the next fact about businesses of
the poor is that these businesses are
very fragile so if you look at this is
Mexico in eighty five percent of the
people poor didn't have a business in
two thousand to fifteen percent had a
business by 2005 out of those fifteen
percent only six percent has still had a
business so sixty percent of all
business is just closed so the they also
going in and out of business all the
time on the other hand many other people
started started new businesses and you
look at the fraction of the people who
retained their existing labor force
that's just one point eight percent so
most people either grow their business
or shrink it but then or shut it down so
business are very very fragile they're
not like very you know it's not that you
set up a business and it lasts forever
it's like it's quite a quite a high-risk
outcome so then it's not surprising and
this is sort of the answer to the
question do you do the poor feel
entrepreneurial and this is survey we've
done in many countries now we always
find the same answer you ask people you
you have a child what do you what
occupation do you hope for your child to
be and we ask it two ways we ask them
one we asked them what what occupation
do you hope for your child then you
might worry if you ask that question
they might be conditioning on their
condition and said look you know my
child he'll never be able to do the
right kind of business because he
doesn't have enough money or something
so he asked them if you want a lottery
and you could invest in something what
was what occupation would this child
want to be in it doesn't make a
difference they always give you the same
answer which is that their own don't
want to be in business the answer is
very very clear eighteen percent want
them to be a private farm employee
forty-one percent to be have a
non-teaching government job and
thirty-four percent to be a government
teacher so that's ninety three percent
don't want them to be an entrepreneur so
basically the poor don't like the idea
at least of the children being
entrepreneurs that's whether or not this
is a this is and it did go it's
consistent with everything else we see
which is that they don't seem to invest
all their time in a single business even
a half a business they don't they put a
part only a part of that time into it
they don't we saw earlier that they
don't try very hard to save their way
out of debt we saw that when we looked
at the fruit vendors that they were not
saving a lot and try to get out of debt
so it seems like they don't seem to be
hugely committed to growing their
business there's no evidence them and we
see the businesses don't grow many of
them shrink or shut down very few of
them actually add an employee at best
these businesses are always small they
stay small or the shutdown they rarely
grow so there is no evidence that the
poor are actually sort of in you know
kind of dynamic entrepreneurs in the
sense that they are sort of they're
looking for opportunities to grow their
business all the time now that doesn't
mean that then
a million dynamic entrepreneurs among
the poor one should not confuse the
statement that the average poor person
is not a dynamic entrepreneur with the
statement that there are no dynamic
entrepreneurs on the board there may be
exactly the same fraction of dynamic
entrepreneurs on the porous there among
MIT students for all I know it just most
people are not cut out to be dynamic
entrepreneurs and and the poor may be
just like everybody else they don't like
risk they don't like the idea of you
know worrying about all the problems
that running a business has they like a
steady job and then a few people really
like being an entrepreneur I don't know
that this is makes them any different
from anybody else it just says that they
are not you see a huge over
representation of the poor among
entrepreneurs that doesn't mean that
this is what the poll want to be it's
not that their entrepreneurial in some
natural sense they're not that they want
to be an entrepreneur their entrepreneur
for some other reason will come come
come to in a minute but it's not the
under the none of this evidence seems to
suggest that they are dying to be
entrepreneurs and to grow their
businesses and become that doesn't mean
that there aren't some who are is this
you know there's this story of that you
saw in the microfinance movie of some
woman who started as a hair collector
remember this person and she is now hair
tycoon and they exist exist people like
that everywhere in the world I'm not I
I'm even willing to believe that the you
know that there are as many genuinely
entrepreneurial people among the poor as
they are among anybody else but that's a
very different sentence from saying that
the poor most poor people have
entrepreneur have businesses because
they are entrepreneurial because they're
so massively over represent
so you would imagine that unless they're
ex-real they're really like you know
unlikely people to be entrepreneurs if
they are entrepreneurs is not because
they want to be this is all consistent
with the fact that if you look at the
these businesses are not really
attractive economically so we actually
one place where we have detailed data we
could actually calculate how much
revenues these businesses making
calculate profits now a key part of the
Prophet calculation remember almost none
of these firms have employees so you
have to evaluate the time spent by the
owner in running the business somehow
how much how do you price that you price
that at minimum wage these businesses
lose money so by just if I went out and
worked at minimum wage I will make more
money than if I if I did this business
and spend all the time on spending in
the business now I'm not necessarily
working as hard in the business as I
would be working in other things but it
isn't the case that I'm making lots of
money I think this is a pattern that
people have noticed now here's a puzzle
I just said they don't make a lot of
money they're not very profitable these
businesses before I all will also told
you that they pay very high interest so
there must be generated extra dollar
must be generating at least that much so
if I am paying sixty percent interest
one dollar must be generating more than
sixty cents when investing a dollar and
in paying sixty percent interest that
one dollar must be generating more than
sixty cents how do those two facts fit
with each other I said a they are not
very profitable be
they are covering they must be the
marginal dollar must be making a high
high return because otherwise they
wouldn't be investing their amazing on
lava you won't borrow money at sixty
percent unless you can cover sixty
percent so we know that they're making
lots of money yeah this book but
basically there's a different app
switcher what is marching on for an
extra dollars that what's the return
the return is so programmable logic
businesses there is a point very early
on which is very high marginal return
that it really levels off so that's kind
of what you run into where it's possible
that if you have a very small missed
like example in the books like let's say
you have a shot but you can't go
anything on the shelves if you spend an
extra twenty dollars and can actually
have like some candy on Michelle's then
that will produce very high marginal
return but if you spend three hundred
dollars and have a lot of higher
employee is risk of stuff spoiling etc
etc so I think that that's absolutely
right but I was making an even simpler
point here which is that think of that
business the the person who set up a
shop the first amount of money you
invest is in you you invest your time
into the shop and you invest the space
you invest the shelves you invest the
inventory then you start selling so in
particular your time is a fixed
investment because you have now decided
that instead of working outside i need
to i'm going to stay in the shop so you
need to cover to become profitable you
need to cover your own daily wage say
lets you let's say you make two dollars
a day then you need to then even if you
made if you may total of two dollars a
day by selling you would have just
covered your wage then you recover your
inventory your capital costs etc so
unless you operate at a high enough
scale you're not going to cover your
cover your time and so one of the
problems these people are often
operating at a very small scale so they
rarely managed to cover their costs
relatedly is the point that may be so
but then why don't these people just
grow their businesses maybe if they are
not making a lot of money because you
know they have to cover their fixed
costs then why not just keep investing
till you make a lot of money and then
you'll certainly you know your marginal
returns are high so you could invest
more and make more money and then the
answer is your marginal returns are high
but they are high for a very wide range
so they start falling fast as well so
this is the picture that is in the book
and it's worth probably understanding is
that picture so that pictures it tells
the story of two technologies there's
one technology which is sort of like you
know gives you a high return but quickly
flattens off and if that was the only
technology in the world that we would
not observe any large firms because
that's a technology which stops becoming
profitable after a point very quickly
but there's another technology which is
which starts way to the right of that
and that technology is only profitable
if you invest so what that curve says is
that there is two technologies
production from technology to is lower
than production for technology one until
you cross a particular point so you need
to make enough investment to make that
profitable so you you know you're going
to buy a machine which produces a lot of
garments but if you can't buy the cloth
that goes with the machine then no point
buying the machine you're going to lose
money for sure because you know you have
nothing to use the machine with garments
need a machine and the need cloth and if
you have you have only money for the god
of the machine then you should not buy
the machine you should buy the machine
only if you can buy the machine and by
the cloth so there there are there are
more profitable technology and less
profitable technologies but the the the
disadvantage of the more profitable
technology stands out to be that you
need to have you need to invest enough
in them to make money so the problem is
that the poor are caught between a kind
of a rock and a hard place which is that
it sound they can't really get up to the
level at which they would make real
money because that technology is just
too expensive for them they don't have
that much money the technology that they
can access has very fast diminishing
returns so that one also is not worth
growing a lot so they are sort of
between a that's the sense in which
there between a rock and a hard place
they they can't grow the technology fast
enough the one that they have they can't
grow and the one that can grow they
can't have and that's what this picture
is about this picture this is what the
world looks like then the poor are stuck
at a point like em and the richer stuck
at a point like you know that second
ball up there and that that's also the
poor are stuck because they can't really
the technology that that has growth is
not available to them and the one that's
available to does not have growth in it
so they're kind of there's no point in
their putting a lot of effort into
growing their technology because they're
really not going to make a lot of money
either way so that's sort of that would
explain why they don't really want to be
entrepreneurs because they know that you
know they're never going to get very far
in this process so then that leaves us
with the last slide and well actually
one slide that suggests that this
picture is a is right is that there's
this experiment in sri lanka where
people were given randomly either five
hundred two hundred fifty dollars or
five hundred dollars for investing and
this was just a gift the world bank
basically did this experiment where it
went to people and said he has two
hundred fifty dollars these were all
small businessmen use it in your
business or do something with it so they
are and some people they offered five
hundred dollars it's kind of a nice
experiment to do because you can find
out what's the effect of getting money
on people's investment and strikingly if
you give two hundred fifty dollars you
get high marginal returns so these
people who get two hundred fifty dollars
invest 250 dollars
and they make about sixty sixty percent
a year on that so that is pretty good
returns on the other hand we give them
five hundred dollars they don't invest
the second 250 they just use it for
repairing the home so they do not
believe that the second five hundred
dollars are going to grow their business
that much more they believe that there
is diminishing returns that's why they
do not invest it so basically the poor
seemed to be acting as if they also
believe exactly that picture that their
high returns on the first 250 but not on
the second 250 yeah
enough money achieve you can jump the
curb by the tech absolutely so as I
technically like that Mike
should work well liberals and how big
the loan is yeah i mean the problem is
that the jump is not at five hundred
dollars the jump is at ten thousand
dollars so you can't really so none of
the launch they're being offered allow
them to make that jump that's the
problem so if you yeah
so that then brings us to the final
question which is if this is all got
such a great deal why are they in
business yeah go ahead yeah one is that
they have to be that they there are so
if they saw here this is not is a
vicious cycle here suppose no one can
create a business that's big enough to
hire hire employees then I can never be
an employee in somebody else's firm what
else can I do I can start my own
business which can't hire anybody so so
if if somebody nobody is creating
businesses which have employees then in
a sense I'm stuck I can't get a job
because nobody else is creating those
jobs but if i canno buddy else is
creating those jobs then I I can't
really work for anybody else but I still
have to earn a living so I go and find
my own you know I find my own thing to
do so I think the primary reason why you
have a lot of entrepreneurs is because
no entrepreneur's big enough to hire the
others so everybody is a entrepreneur
mini entrepreneur nobody gets to scale
where they can hire others and therefore
everybody's kind of stuck so you know if
I I don't if I start a business that has
ten people then that stops nine other
people for being an entrepreneur that's
one reason a second reason has to do
with flexibility I think a lot of poor
people don't have access to social
services so if you I have to if I have
to like have childcare pay for childcare
I'm never going to be afford my business
because charge gets too expensive so I'm
going to actually the only way I'm going
to have a business is that if so if I
have to go out and get a job which is
nine to five and have to work all the
time who's going to provide childcare so
often they choose choose businesses
which are designed to work well with
childcare like I can I took a make a
snack
business why because I can do it at home
I make the snacks at home and then I go
out to sell for two hours at that time I
take my child with me and then I bring
the child back and that that way I don't
ever have to deal with the childcare
issues so flexibility is a second one
third and most worrying one is you were
and this is microcredit makes me worry
about this most is whether or not a lot
of men are very enthusiastic for the
wives to work even harder so they feel
that you know I'm working at a job I
would like my wife to work harder and
the way they get their wives to work
harder it was making them start a
business so so I don't know whether
microcredit is necessarily wonderful for
all these women so I worry that maybe I
think historically men have found it
difficult to understand that women even
though they don't go out to work
actually have to work that like cooking
and cleaning dishes and and washing up
are all hard work and if you think that
that's a problem in the US now then you
can imagine them lot of developing
countries is even more of a problem so
it may well be that a lot of men under
under the illusion that they were wives
are idle and that they are very willing
therefore to start a business for them
so they can work a little harder and add
to the family pie so I don't know how
much of these businesses are a result of
that rather than any desire to start a
business
comments
so just to close this whole thing I
think the key policy question that we
don't know the answer to is how to get
businesses not get more businesses but
more businesses that hire other people
that's the P policy question we haven't
managed to solve yet and it's absolutely
central policy question for most
developing countries to figure out how
to get like you know not not micro
businesses but small businesses and that
that transition from and this is often
called the missing middle problem it's
called many countries in poor countries
you find that there are many micro
businesses and some large businesses but
not enough so middle sized businesses so
that's the policy problem that many many
countries are wrestling with and it's
one that I think we haven't yet got a
very good handle on but it's it's
something to think about is how to
generate those jobs yeah those
so for one the state does a lot like in
the US for example there's a Community
Reinvestment Act which means that in you
have to provide a certain fraction banks
are required to provide a certain
fraction of the loans to the community
where they are raising the savings so
either the cscr a forces them then to
finance local businesses and so there is
a lot of intervention even in a country
as an interventionist as the u.s. to
help poor you know small business who
set up this you know CRA is a very good
example the Small Business
Administration is huge in the US by the
way and they provide all kinds of help
to small businesses including capital
including guarantees to give a lot of
loan guarantees so this this is even the
US which is one of the world's least
interventionist countries tends to be
very interventionist when it comes to
promoting small businesses and that's I
think it so that might that's probably
the direction that policy needs to go in
developing countries but it's it's
something we know less about okay thank
you